uh yeah when he met Guru Pitta and he  had to learn how to detach himself from  worldly possessions because he wanted to  be able to control the Avatar state  there were seven chakras he had to  unlock and one of them was Detachment  the hardest one for him was to  detachables was from Katara but for me  what am I attached to  I guess my family first of all because  they will always be there they've been  there before all this happened  they've been there before all this so  they will always be there so I'm  attached to them  um my dogs keep them with me  um I'm attached to them  and my  uh my gym yes my training my training my  my values in that space But yeah any  material things I'm not really attached  to